for the past two nights we've been
bringing you stories of harassment on
Capitol Hill and the news about senator
Al Franken today underscores the
importance of our reporting tonight
another woman joins us to speak about
her experience she claims a former
congressman asked her to perform for him
at the time she knew nothing of the
congressional office set up to deal with
incidents like this but she's joining us
now
Rebecca weir is making these accusations
and we're also joined by attorney les
Alderman
who's been litigating cases under this
Congressional Accountability Act for the
past 15 years lesson Rebecca good to see
both of you Rebecca let's start with you
tell us your story and it happened quite
a while ago in 2000 I believe but tell
us the facts yes so it was right out of
college I was eager to get my first job
I was a government major and so I knew I
wanted to work in public service
I found congressman Miller's office it
was a great fit
it was eager to work there was proud to
work there I loved working there and I
excelled at my job while I was there we
came the member was in DC He gives
coming back for the August recess and I
was eager to talk to him because I've
been working on a proposal for several
weeks before he returned to the district
so I went to his office to give the
presentation as I was walking out after
the presentation was over he stopped me
and he said Wow
Rebecca you just look amazing I mean
just really stunning would you mind just
twirling for me and I was wearing a
dress suit at the time and I was stunned
I didn't know what to do I was a 22 year
old inexperienced and this was a member
that I respected and he was doing really
great work in Congress and I didn't know
what else to do but to comply with his
request
and so you so he asked you just let me
paint the picture for our listeners he
asked you in the hallway office to twirl
okay yeah this is in his office even
says something like so stupid so what'd
you say he says you look you look
amazing look great
twirl I mean I just said you know that's
just a odd thing to say first of all and
so you were you're 22 and so would you
twirl fast slow hugged you twirl what
was the twirl it twirl like I'm sure it
was fast because I was so humiliated by
the experience you know I I was very
aware of the fact that in just a few
seconds I had gone from young
professional to a piece of meat and I
felt like he was undressing me with his
eyes and I tried to leave as fast as I
could I went back to my desk I sat down
I tried to regroup and while I was
trying to make heads or tails of the
situation I got a phone call from our DC
office informing me congratulations
Rebecca we don't know what she did but
Gary just called and he wants to give
you a bonus effective immediately and it
gutted me at the time because I knew
exactly what I had done I twirled for
him I let myself be reduced to
essentially a piece of meat and now that
I do did you what did you say well I
went I'm sorry to interrupt we gotta get
to less but before we get to less
Rebecca did you take the bonus you know
I really grappled with this and I really
hated that I was in the situation of
having to choose between my economic
stability and my integrity but I was 22
years old
I didn't have a choice I was I'm not
criticizing you I'm not criticizing you
I think this is so it's so outrageous
that this happens on Capitol Hill but I
want to get you here yeah yeah no no way
no we're finding out it's just it's it's
it's all too common and there's a lot
worse than twirling going on as well
listen I want to get into this with you
you litigate these cases they can be as
as quick of an encounter as a leer and a
twirl I guess or something much more
involved and they how many people have
come how many people have come to you
over the past 15 years and allege these
types of incidents you know we don't
keep the numbers for harassment versus
discrimination versus retaliation but I
can tell you that numerous women have
come forward not only at who work in
Congress but who work in other areas of
Capitol Hill the architect of the
Capitol the Library of Congress the
Supreme Court the Capitol Police this is
happening all in all of these places and
what I can say is right now when all of
these brave women are coming forward and
we're shining the spotlight on what's
happening this is when we have to do
something to fix the situation to make
it better because I'm sorry but four
weeks from now the news cycle is going
to move on we're going to be on the next
crisis or the next story and no one's
gonna care anymore so we need to fix
this situation now we need to strengthen
the law now we need to expand the
protections to these unpaid interns
these fellows who currently are not
covered by the law we need to remove
that confidentiality provision so that
women don't have to fear speaking out
about their cases and about their claims
we have to make sure that everyone who's
working on the hill understands that if
they think that they may be
discriminated against or they may be
being harassed that there is a place for
them to go that they have rights that
they can ultimately file a lawsuit and
let the bright light of litigation
now bring their cases forward and that's
unfortunately it's not happening I'm
gonna get back okay I want to get to
back to Rebecca do you know other women
during the time that you worked on the
hill who experienced something like what
you experienced or worse and how many
approximate yes of course I hate to say
this but almost all of us had our own
stories that's how pervasive the
culture of harassment is this is the
quintessential old boys club it has
probably been this way since its
inception given the power dynamics at
play and it has as les was just talking
about there is no check there is no
accountability there's no reason that
anyone would avoid these kinds of
behaviors it's it's totally
unaccountable so Rebecca your
congressman was congressman Malloy I
couldn't I couldn't hear her swing Gary
Miller congressman Miller Miller Miller
okay Miller yeah yeah
Gary Mel about you you're still friends
with him though aren't you you respect
him still yes I do and I'm glad that you
asked that question
you know he's a good man and Goodman
sometimes acts badly and I think that's
the case here
my motivation in coming forward is not
to grind an axe a fifteen-year-old
vendetta I am motivated to help empower
women who are coming after me the 22
year olds of today who are working on
the hill to help them speak in the
moment to help them know they're
important and that they can come out and
they have options available to them and
if I may say yeah yeah yeah and it's
really incredible of you to be friends
with him I mean that's a that's amazing
I mean that's that says a lot about you
maybe you look past that and but a lot
of people have gone through a lot of bad
stuff on Capitol Hill and I want the
people's names I don't want the
confidentiality I want all the names
because the settlements are paid but we
don't know who the names are and that is
outrageous both of you thank you for
joining us